The Nawawi Rahimullah mentions the
narration here. This is considered one
of the
encompassing, most comprehensive
narrations
in all of the Sunnah.
So much so that Al-Hafiz An-Nawawi
Rahimullah
made this one of the
select 42 narrations that he chose for
that very
important, very grave, and and
substantial book.
And so, the point of that book, and why
it's important for us to
point out that it was included in the 40
narrations,
is that that book
aims to comprehensive
statements of the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. So comprehensive
that when we look at that book, 42
narrations in total,
Al-Hafidh ibn Rajab came after and added
eight more narrations. So he made them
50 in total.
Every single verse in the Quran can be
rooted back to one of those 50
narrations. Every single one.
Every single verse.
Those narrations draw from every one of
the verses of the Quran and every one of
the verses of the Quran draw from those
50 narrations. And this is why
students typically begin with memorizing
those 50 narrations because they are
essentially more or less the foundation
of all of the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's Sunnah. Let me ask you a
question. Where does most of the Sunnah
come from?
I mean, we know that it's revelation.
It's wahy, right?
But
is is it to be understood that every
single statement he made, Jibril came
down and told him verbatim, "Say these
exact words in this exact order" every
time he spoke? Is that how the Sunnah
works?
No, that's not how the Sunnah works.
The Sunnah
of the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is largely, if not mostly,
based on the confirmation of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Meaning that Allah sends down the Quran,
the prophet
Alayhi Wasallam learns from it.
And he
extrapolates
much of his words from the Quoran.
And if he is to make a mistake,
Jibril will immediately correct him.
If he does not make a mistake, and that
is incredibly rare, right? We only have
like
five or six instances in the whole
Sunnah, and there was a purpose to that
mistake. It was to learn something.
If Jibril
does not correct him, then it is assumed
that it is what?
It is correct. What he says is
derivative of the Quoran.
Largely, if not most, of everything he
said is what he understood from the
Quoran. And this is why we always begin
with the Quoran.
Because in order to properly properly
contextualize the Sunnah, we have to
understand
where he draws most of his conclusions
from.
[Silence]
Allah
says that he sent down the Quoran upon
the prophet
Alayhi Wasallam
so that he would judge
between the people
with that which Allah has shown him. Al
Shafi said, "Every single judgment the
prophet made
was all from a result of what he
understood from the Quran.
Here we get a direct reference from the
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam to
the Quran.
He says, Abu Huraira narrates that the
messenger of Allah Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said,
"Oh people, indeed Allah is pure and
good and he will only accept that which
is pure and good.
And indeed Allah has commanded the
believers with the same thing that he
has commanded the messengers.
Allah has said to the messengers, 'Oh
messengers,
eat and consume from that which is good
and pure and do righteous.'
And he has said to the believers, 'Oh
you who have believed, consume and eat
from that which is good and pure of what
we have blessed you with, what we have
sustained you with.'
So, what do we understand from this? We
understand
that in order for a person to be
accepted by Allah,
they have to be what?
Pure.
This is a purity that a person has to
have in order to be fit to be accepted
by Allah.
And the first thing
that the human being
is is what he consumes, what you put
into your body
of anything
is going to result in what your body is
made up of.
I think that's pretty clear, right? And
we're not just talking about food.
Food is only one of the many, many, many
things that human beings consume.
We're talking about food, drink, we're
talking about what you listen to, what
you watch, what you look at, what you
smell, what you feel, what you do. Any
action that you take is type of
consumption. You are consuming. You are
taking this physical outside world and
you are putting it into your heart and
into your soul.
And so,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has commanded
that we only consume that which is pure.
Because Allah is pure and will only
accept that which is what? That which is
pure. And this teaches us why there are
some people that have to go to the
hellfire before they go into paradise.
Why?
To burn out and burn off
all of the impurities
that they have accumulated because of
their misdeeds before they can be
allowed into the purest of places, which
is paradise.
Correct? We've spoken about the
the connectivity between the people
of paradise and paradise itself. We've
spoken about this before.
That paradise
is a living place, a living breathing
place that is connected on some level to
the people that it inhabit it.
And that is why it moves with the people
and it
accommodates the people in a way that
is beyond words. When they desire
something, all they have to do is merely
desire it and it is presented by this
place of paradise. Why? Because it is a
result of their deeds. It is an
extension of them.
And so,
a person will only be
accepted when a person is pure
or purified. And this is why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
qad aflaha man
ishq
qad aflaha man tazakka very good. That's
not the one I had in mind.
Another one qad aflaha man
zakkaha
tazakka same meaning more or less.
And that is who is the successful? The
one who has purified and enhanced
his soul, his nafs.
Because zakah is not just purification,
it's enhancement as well.
A zakah fil lughah huwa an namuw.
It's something that grows.
So it is an enhancement and a
purification.
So
what are we commanded to do? We
understand this principle. What is the
principle?
Allah is pure and will only accept that
which is pure.
The only thing that is of Allah is that
Okay. And so where does our purity
begin? With what we consume.
And we can only be as good in our
actions as we are good in our
consumption.
If we consume filth, we can never
produce good.
Right? And this is why it's very
dangerous that a person allow even his
mind
to ponder and think about negative
things.
Because what is
a person's thoughts? Every single deed,
good or bad, always begins where?
With the thought.
He then says
thumma dhakara rajulun yutilu safara
ash'atha aghbara ash'ath ya'ni sha'ruhu
ghayr mumashshat aghbar
yamuddu yadaihi ila as-sama' ya rabb ya
[Arabic recitation]
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam gave an
example
of a man
who is in a long journey. His hair is
uncombed.
His clothing is dusty from that journey.
He is extending and reaching his hands
out to the heavens saying, "Ya Rab, oh
Lord, oh Rab, Rab."
All right, so he's making dua.
So, these are five things that make a
person that enhance a person's dua.
Why do we raise our hands in dua?
Because raising the hands in dua is an
enhancement to our dua.
Certain words that we use are an
enhancement to our dua. When we go to a
certain place and make dua there, it's
an enhancement to our dua. These are
five enhancing
elements to this man's dua.
First of all, his hair is unkempt and
his clothing is dusty.
He is on a long travel. The travel is
something that enhances a person's dua.
So much so that the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells us that the dua of
the traveler is accepted by Allah. What
does that mean accepted? Meaning it is
enhanced. It is more likely to be
accepted by Allah.
He raises his hands, which is another
enhancer of dua.
And he uses Ya Rab.
And Ya Rab or Rab, this particular word,
this name of Allah,
this is one of the greatest enhancers of
dua of all of the names of Allah.
That's why in all the major duas in the
Quran, what is the word that is used to
refer to Allah? Rab.
Rab.
[Arabic recitation]
the messengers in their dua,
Rabbi.
So, these are five enhancers of dua,
right?
Humility
and travel and
However, he's still not his dua is not
accepted. Why? Why is his dua not
accepted?
The prophet tells us sallallahu alayhi
wasallam,
his food
is from haram.
And his drink is from haram. And his
clothing is from haram. And he has
nourished his body
from haram.
So, how could this man's dua ever be
accepted? That's how he says it. He
frames it in that way. How could it ever
be accepted?
Will Allah always accept a person's dua?
Dua has
conditions and it has
prohibited prohibitors.
Things that if a person does it, it will
prohibit their dua from being accepted.
Right? Mawani.
And so, when a person makes dua, the
essential
or the natural state
of Allah's connection with his creation,
[Arabic recitation]
Your Lord has proclaimed and said, "Call
upon me and I will
respond."
However, if a person does something
that prohibits response or if a person
fails to fulfill a condition of dua,
then it's the same thing as salah.
Salah has conditions, right? Salah has
pillars, it has obligations, it ha it
has things that nullify it, correct? And
dua is no different.
And one of the nullifiers of dua is
what?
That a person eats,
drink,
clothe himself, sustain himself, nourish
himself with haram.
Either something that is haram in itself
or something that has been acquired by
way of haram.
This is a
man of dua. This will stop a person's
dua.
It will nullify a person's dua before it
even makes it past his lips.
And so,
a lot of times when people
say, you know, I I prayed, but my
prayers were not answered.
Allah said,
Falyastajibuli.
Hal antastajabta lillah qabla an yujibak
Allah?
Allah said, "Make dua to me, I will
answer. If you If my slaves ask you
about me, I am near. I answer the dua of
those who call upon me and pray to me,
so let them in turn respond to my call.
Have you responded to Allah's call
before making the dua?
Right?
It is no different than a person saying,
"I made salah, but my salah was
invalid." Did you make wudu?
Did you make ghusl? Did you cover your
awrah? Did you face the qibla?
Did you make salah in its time? Did you
have intention? These are all conditions
of salah.
If any one of them is not fulfilled,
then the salah is invalid.
Very simple.
Right?
And so, dua is no different. It has
conditions, it has pillars, it has
mawani. And if a person sabotages
himself, then he has no one but himself
to what? To blame.